la pénurie de main d'oeuvre à chambouler
le marché du travail cette année les
employeurs peinent à recruter et les
employés sont nombreux à vouloir en
profiter pour améliorer leurs conditions
l'entreprise de recrutement anywhere
adressait un portrait des tendances 2023
en recrutement et pour nous en parler on
reçoit Pascal reçu vice-président du
développement des affaires chez newer
Canada bonjour madame rochu bonjour
Alors on sent que les employés demandent
plus qu'il y a de plus en plus d'attente
de leur part c'est ce que vous notez
dans votre rapport à quel point est-ce
que les employés vont avoir le gros bout
du bâton les candidats pour l'an
prochain je pense que cette tendance va
continuer à se confirmer comme vous
l'avez mentionné les emplois sont
nombreux les candidats moins nombreux
donc ils ont l'embarras du choix ils
vont rechercher de la flexibilité ils
vont chercher des emplois qui va leur
permettre de pouvoir continuer à se
former qui vont leur permettre d'évoluer
dans un milieu sain et bien rien donc il
garde le gros bout du bâton pour l'année
prochaine certainement quelles sont les
demandes les plus fréquentes est-ce que
c'est le salaire je vous dirais que le
salaire tombe en troisième place ce qui
est le plus important chez les candidats
c'est vraiment une flexibilité donc
pouvoir jongler vie sociale familiale et
professionnelle c'est
de travailler dans une entreprise qui
reflète aussi leur valeur ils sont de
plus en plus nombreux à exiger par
exemple qu'on qu'on travaille dans un
contexte tout l'employeur va considérer
l'environnement comme étant quelque
chose d'important donc voilà et en
termes de télétravail on en a beaucoup
parlé au terme au cours des derniers
mois c'est devenu très très répandu
est-ce que c'est vraiment un critère de
la part des candidats de pouvoir faire
du télétravail oui je crois que les
employeurs le qui veulent revoir leurs
employés à temps plein vont devoir
prendre leur mal en place en patience
puisque c'est plus de 80% des candidats
qui au sondage en disant qu'ils
cherchent vraiment une flexibilité soit
une moitié du temps à la maison une
moitié du temps en entreprise pour
pouvoir justement le jongler famille vie
sociale professionnelle épargner du
temps dans le transport etc 80% c'est
quand même élevé il faut vraiment que
les entreprises s'adaptent le même si la
pandémie le confinement sont un petit
peu moins présentes je pense que c'est
une tendance qui va rester qui va
perdurer qu'il y avait déjà commencé je
crois avant la pandémie mais la pandémie
nous a donné les lampes pour dire ben
c'est possible de le faire et de rester
productif l'autre tendance que vous
notez c'est que des gens sont prêts à
quitter un emploi pour devenir
consultant donc vraiment changer leur
façon de travailler complètement pour
avoir plus de souplesse pourquoi
qu'est-ce qu'exactement quelle forme ça
prend en fait de plus en plus je crois
de
candidats qui se disent ben si je suis
pas capable d'aller chercher chez un
employeur ce que je recherche à 100% les
missions qui m'interpellent à 100% je
vais créer mon propre mon propre emploi
alors ça permet par exemple de faire un
contrat chez un employeur un contrat
chez un autre employeur et d'aller
chercher à la pièce ce qu'on recherche
chez plusieurs employeurs différents
donc plus de souplesse est-ce que c'est
plus payant aussi de travailler comme ça
c'est plus payant probablement sur
certains aspects mais il reste que quand
on est à son propre compte on a pas
accès à des assurances on doit prendre
en charge ce genre de choses donc il y a
des bons côtés des avantages et des
inconvénients évidemment à chaque à
chaque façon de faire vous notez aussi
que le processus de recrutement est en
train de changer que les étapes sont
plus rapides comment ça se passe
maintenant quand quelqu'un veut recruter
en fait par exemple les sites internet
les sites internet où on allait se
chercher une emploi qui était très
généraliste sur de moins en moins
populaires on va se tourner vers des
sites qui sont beaucoup plus
spécialisées par exemple un site
internet qui va afficher des emplois qui
sont en marketing en RH pour les
journaliers et je pense que de plus en
plus les employeurs vont devoir se
tourner vers la technologie faire par
exemple des entrevues virtuelles pour
accélérer le processus d'embauche ou
quand on cherche pour des emplois plus
spécialisés utiliser l'intelligence
artificielle pour nous aider à aller
chercher le les meilleurs CV le plus
rapidement possible aux États-Unis il y
a des employeurs qui ont même carrément
abandonnés l'entrevue d'embauche pour
certains postes un petit peu moins
exigeants est-ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous voyez ici nous on n'a pas été
témoin de ça et je pense que c'est
peut-être une mode qui va passer très
rapidement parce que ça coûte cher
toutes ces processus embauchés quelqu'un
l'intégrer c'est des dépenses c'est du
temps et si on s'aperçoit qu'on s'est
trompé mais c'est de l'argent on va
investi pour rien alors moi je pense que
quand même le l'entrevue le processus
d'embauche va évoluer mais il y a une
certaine
tradition là où il y a on doit parler
pour s'assurer que l'employé le futur
employé à Dar à nos valeurs par exemple
en tant qu'entreprise je pense que ça
c'est appelé à rester quelqu'un qui veut
changer d'emploi l'an prochain si vous
aviez un conseil à lui donner pour sa
recherche d'emploi ben je lui dirai de
pas faire de compromis puisque il a le
gros bout du bâton c'est c'est à lui de
d'établir ses priorités puis de bien de
bien faire ses recherches et de je suis
certaine que ce qu'il recherche se
trouve sur le marché présentement donc
demandé un meilleur salaire des
conditions aussi à tous les avantages
sociaux également la flexibilité vous le
disiez il y a plusieurs éléments dont il
faut tenir compte certainement merci
beaucoup madame Brochu d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir merci bonne soirée pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI